good afternoon my name is adrian dix i'm
bc's minister of health
and i'm here uh on the territory of the
luang and speaking people the sangees
and esquimalt first nations dr bonnie
henry our provincial health officer is
in vancouver on the territory of the
musqueam of the squamish of the slava
tooth and it's my honor to introduce dr
bonnie henry
thank you very much and good afternoon
i want to start by acknowledging today
that the world is a little bit more
uncertain
and for some people that can be
provoking anxiety and and fear
and particularly with and
years with the covid pandemic and
the number of climate disasters that we
have been through here in bc and i know
that this weighs on us and especially on
children and i want to remind people
there is help
i want to remind people about the kids
helpline in particular
eight six 1-800-668-6868
or you can text six eight six eight six
six eight and reach out and talk to
somebody
these are times when we need to connect
with each other and support each other
and especially for our children
having said that we are seeing some very
encouraging trends that set us
well for the path ahead here in british
columbia in many parts of our province
the transmission of cobit is down which
in turn is relieving the intense
pressure that we have had on our
hospitals and on the broader health care
system
at the same time there are still many
many areas that have significant
transmission and we are still seeing
widespread transmission of this virus
across the province which is why those
protections we have in place
right now remain a necessary part of our
strategy for now
as we move into march today being march
1st we have committed to monitoring
these to making sure that we
can
make the changes that are needed based
on our best data and our pandemic and
we've talked about the importance of
doing this prior to spring break and
that is something we have committed to
and we'll be looking at additional
precautions and what we
if we're in a better place to be able to
remove some of additional measures
very soon
this morning i had the the opportunity
to spend some time with immunizers
across bc and across parts of western
canada in the bc immunization forum
and it was really an opportunity to
reflect on the incredible work of so
many people that have gotten us to this
point in the pandemic
we've delivered over 11 million doses of
vaccines
in every corner of british columbia and
people
immunizers from all walks of life have
been stepping up and doing a tremendous
job and i just want to express my
gratitude for the heroic work that
they've done across the province and
continue to do to support people in
making those important decisions and i
want to thank british columbians for
stepping up and getting vaccinated
some of our newest tools are new types
of vaccines the vaccines the protein
subunit vaccines novavax which we talked
a little bit about last week and a
number of questions have come in so i
just want to
talk about a number of them the nova vax
vaccine is approved for use for people
18 and above it is not yet been tested
in younger children
it is safe to mix and match so if you've
had an mrna vaccine or viral vector
vaccine as your first dose
and you've had concerns or
side effects from that you can use this
as a dose too you don't need to start
again so novavax can be your second dose
in the primary series and it should be
at about eight weeks it can also be used
as a booster dose if you've had two
doses of any other vaccine so it is safe
to mix and match there is no need to
start again and for those people who
have not yet
started
your course of vaccination novavax is a
perfect opportunity for you to rethink
that and get the protection that others
have so if anybody is interested in
novak novovax you can call
1-833-838-2323 and put yourself on the
list and i know we have
close to a thousand people at least
already on that list and as soon as it
comes into the province in the next few
days we'll be making arrangements for
you to get your dose
in addition last week health canada
approved the medicago
vaccine which is a really interesting
plant-based vaccine
it uses what we call a virus-like
particle that is developed in plants and
again it provides the entire protein to
your immune system so it's different
from the mrna vaccines where you get the
code for developing that protein and it
is packaged
with a similar adjuvant to
what we used for the h1n1 influenza
vaccine and it's a similar type of
vaccine to the ones we have for hpv and
hepatitis so it is a more
one that we're more used to
i will say that it is only approved for
use for people 18 to 64. they didn't
have a number of older people in the
trials so right now there's no reason to
believe it's not effective in older
people but the data is not there so it
is for people 18 to 20 64 years of age
unfortunately though we're not expected
to receive any of this vaccine in the in
the province or the country
for the next few months
i will say
vaccination is our key it's the key that
we have had for getting through this
past two waves both delta and omicron
it's made a tremendous difference in
reducing transmission and we see that
particularly with the booster dose and
yes the booster dose is effective at
preventing you from getting
infected with omicron we've seen that
it's 60 70 percent
data from quebec shows that it's 80
percent protective on uh preventing you
from needing to go to an emergency
department and we know that it's highly
protective at
preventing hospitalizations or icu care
so i am encouraging everybody who has
not yet had it to get your booster dose
it will help you now and will help you
for what we will be dealing with in the
future and i will remind people that in
hospital right now thankfully we have
decreased numbers of people but 47
percent of the people in our icus are
people who don't have that protection
that vaccines have been giving us and
that comes from about eight percent of
the population
you are much much more likely to get
severe illness if you don't have the
protection if you don't have your immune
system stimulated by vaccination to
recognize this virus when you're exposed
to it and it's still about 20 times more
likely that you're going to have a more
severe illness and i know people have
sent me notes about the fact that
there's more people
by numbers in hospital who have had
vaccines but that is because so many of
us are now protected through vaccination
and some people yes are at most more
risk but your risk is still that much
greater if you don't have that
protection from your immune system that
vaccination gives and i liken it to the
analogy of we all know people who've
smoked for long periods of time and not
everybody develops lung cancer but your
risk of smoking and developing lung
cancer is much much higher than a
non-smoker
very similar to what we're seeing with
vaccination
as has been the case throughout the
pandemic we all have a role to play and
we need to make decisions based on our
personal risk and the risk of those
around us the responsibility of us in
public health is to give you the tools
and resources to be able to manage and
to understand that risk and as we've
seen
as we've gone through this period we've
come to understand a lot more we know
that the most important tool remains
protection through immunization but we
also now have more access to things like
tests that help you make those decisions
about your own health
if you develop symptoms
looking ahead as we expect transmission
to continue to decrease
and the weather gets warmer and we get
into spring we spend more time outside
we will likely no longer need those
extra layers of protection that we've
had in place during this peak of
transmission during the last few weeks
of course this is not the case for
everyone we know that some people people
who are immune compromised people who
are older will need to continue to take
a cautious approach and this is where
again we need to work together to do
what is right for us and to respect
that other people have different risk
and that understanding that masking is
important for people everybody right now
but it will continue to be important for
a number of people keeping that
respectful distance
knowing that not everybody will be
moving at the same pace
keeping groups small will remain
important for many people
as we are getting close to spring we
know that respiratory season tends to
wane but we know as well that it tends
to increase in the as the winter months
come again
so we will have continued uncertainty as
we move through the summer
we hopefully will be in a good place
for the next few months because of the
immunity that we have and where we are
to be able to to relieve the pressure
that some of these measures are in place
but we need to be prepared for immunity
to wane again and for us to have
new approaches and adapt depending on
what we see come the fall
we have all experienced the impacts of
this pandemic and without a doubt it has
been difficult
that is why we will be removing
restrictions and layers of protection as
soon as we are confident we can safely
make those changes and we can support
everybody in doing that
we are being cautious we have heard loud
and clear that we need to be thoughtful
and move cautiously and slowly because
that is the way that we will
continue to gain ground and not lose it
each step of the way we will make the
decisions based on what we're seeing on
the data that we're seeing here in our
pandemic
at the time at the same time i am very
optimistic that we are moving to a
better place rapidly and we'll have more
to say about that very soon i know
things like graduations and performances
and concerts and many workplaces are now
moving to full in-person return to work
if that hasn't occurred already we are
in a transition period but we will take
it slowly and sustainably as we move
into the next little part
this pandemic has also shown us the
importance
of connection
even virtual connection and now more
than ever we need to continue to support
ourselves
to make sure that we reach out and
connect with those in our life right now
people we may not have connected to to
build those bridges as we move into this
transition phase and make sure that we
continue to support each other
with compassion and with love
it is important to know that the things
that we do make a difference to everyone
in our world whether we're doing it
for those we love and for those we don't
know it is important for us to now with
all of the uncertainty that we're facing
to reach out and connect and support
each other as we've been through this
storm together thank you
thank you dr henry and
today i'm providing an update on
rapid test deployment and surgical
renewal but first i wanted to give a
brief update on the impact of sickness
on health care workers and the health
care systems
health authorities continue to closely
monitor sickness levels across health
services especially in hospitals
long-term care and home support i can
report that from february 21st to
february 27
13
631 health care workers called in sick
that includes
3121 in the fraser health authority 2
2517 in interior health
1299 in northern health
1293 in the provincial health services
authority that includes bc emergency
health services our ambulance paramedics
2137 in vancouver coastal health
2679 in island health
and 585 in providence healthcare just to
put that in context february 21st to
27th that's thirteen thousand six thirty
one
last week february fourteenth to twenty
fourteen thousand five seventy nine
february seventh to thirteenth
uh fifteen thousand five hundred forty
two january thirty first to february 6
17
158 each week the number is lower
although it's still above what we would
normally expect at this time of year but
it shows the same thing as other
as other indicators that dr henry has
referred to the fact that
hospitalizations are half of what they
were less than half what they were at
the peak of the omicron variant of
concerned
wave
once again i want to express gratitude
to health care workers who continue to
lead us through the pandemic for their
endurance and their skills today is bc
care providers day and health care
workers particularly in long-term care
and assisted living are being celebrated
today i encourage everyone to find a way
to celebrate
those health care workers you know
members of the hospital employees union
the health sciences association the bcnu
the bcgu the doctors of bc
the union of food the ufcw food and
commercial workers and others who are
significant players in the healthcare
system and all those operating and
running our long-term care and assisted
living facilities across bc
and now an update on rapid tests as of
february 28th bc has received 24 million
56 910 rapid tests we continue to
prepare for the arrival of 12 million
tests over the next four weeks at a rate
of 3 million per week
17 million 525 751
have been deployed to key strategic
areas
as previously noted just over half a
million tests in our inventory are not
suitable for deployment or personal use
and are being used at the discretion of
medical health officers in the
appropriate setting they need a health
professional to do the tests that leaves
a current inventory of five million nine
hundred and seventy four thousand tests
suitable for self-administered use
across the province
to date
3.3 million tests have been distributed
to k-12 schools across the province 2.1
million tests been distributed to
post-secondary institutions already
distributed 2.5 million tests haven't
been delivered to more than 900
pharmacies with more pharmacies
receiving deliveries soon an additional
six hundred thousand tests will be sent
to pharmacies this week
as announced those week these tests are
for british columbians aged 70 and older
to pick up a kit containing five tests
at participating pharmacies this age
group is a priority as we've said many
times because the evidence indicates
they are at
more risk of serious consequences if
they become infected if they become
symptomatic the test will allow them to
determine if they may have a clovid 19
if they may have covet 19 so that other
actions can be taken as required
as of yesterday afternoon pharmacies as
of yesterday end of day pharmacies have
delivered approximately 366 000 tests
that's more than 70 thousand seniors 70
and above have received their tests for
more information on accessing test kits
british columbians can visit bc
pharmacy.ca to get the location in their
community it's important to remember
that testing continues to be something
that we do when we have symptoms that
hasn't changed
increased test availability means more
members of the general population will
be able to access tests to use to
understand their own symptoms and
illness and to take actions to limit
transmission to their friends family and
work including and especially those at
higher risk
and now finally here's our weekly
surgical renewal update
health authorities
report that
6428 surgeries were completed from
january 30th to february 5th
from january from february 20th to
february 26 our most recent week health
authorities postponed 99 non-urgent
scheduled surgeries
that's two in fraser health
92 in interior health one in vancouver
coastal health two in northern health
two in the provincial health services
authority
cumulatively from september 5th 2021 to
february 26 2022 regional surges of
covet and the factors including severe
weather patterns have caused 8025
surgical post moments
for several weeks now
um
with uh with hospitalizations through
the covet high and with a great many
patients with cova in our icus we've
talked about our role in bringing those
numbers down we've said our work our
work together makes the difference that
matters and here's how
this week all health authorities that's
fraser health interior health northern
health vancouver coastal health
vancouver island health and the
provincial health services authority all
our health authorities began scheduling
and completing postponed surgeries all
of them
we've also talked about how each moment
matters as is the difference we make in
it and the difference we've made to
patients who wish to proceed with our
postponed surgeries by stopping kovit's
rapid spread and easing the stress on
our hospitals is just as impressive and
here's why
because 99.8 of patients whose surgeries
were postponed in the first wave have
had their surgeries
because 94.2 percent of patients who
surgery was postponed in ways two and
three have had their surgeries and
because 49.2 percent of patients whose
surgeries were postponed in ways four
and five have now had their surgeries as
well i think it's worthy of pause by all
of us to think how just how welcome this
news is for patients across bc for the
families and friends supportive of them
their care and their well-being and how
much it says about everyone involved in
delivering surgeries and in that it
reminds us our work is not done these
achievements demonstrate again all that
is possible of the progress that is ours
to make
and here's what i think we need to do
now
take care as restrictions ease as we've
all been out and about more we need to
take care ease into activities we
haven't done for a while and make sure
we're ready for the change the demands
it places on us and the attention it
requires of us
take care of think of those all of those
who deliver our care make our surgeries
possible
take care and support residents in
long-term care and keep our hospitals
doing all the remarkable things that
they do take care of ourselves and each
other to ease the workload on them
whenever we can
that's the work we need to do now and
with that we're happy to take your
questions
a reminder to reporters on the line
please press star one to enter the queue
you will be limited to one question and
one follow-up our first question today
comes from lisa cordasco vancouver sun
thank you
um as we move into this new phase what
type of surveillance systems would you
put in place to you know accurately
monitor any transmission in the
community or to be able to identify
variants in the future
thank you for that that's a really great
thank you i think it's a really great
question i didn't talk about uh
surveillance we did talk about it a
couple of weeks ago but this is what
we're working on with our team um
the particularly at the bccdc but we
have a number of different things we are
going to be moving to a weekly report
rather than the daily numbers and
hopefully that will be very soon as well
and what we will be looking at is
integrating
the surveillance that we're doing for
covid into our
serious respiratory illness surveillance
that we have all along so there will be
ongoing testing from sentinel physicians
we've got a
way of doing that that we do for
influenza that will be including covid
we're looking at expanding the
wastewater testing surveillance that
we're doing over time and expanding it
not just for sarsko v2 but for other
pathogens to help us understand
what's circulating in communities around
the province
we are looking at how do we use
regularly routinely collected blood for
other reasons to help us understand if
we're seeing an increase in and
zero prevalence of covid so these are
all things that are we're adapting and
modifying what we're doing now as we're
in this transition phase so we'll have
more details about that but it will be
looking at how do we make sure we have a
way of seeing a snapshot on a periodic
basis of what's happening
the other really really important thing
is we are continuing our whole genome
sequencing and the sampling that we're
doing and how much we send for whole
genome sequencing will vary as we see
transmission and
amount of virus circulating in the
communities decreasing over the summer
hopefully
so that we're prepared for the fall so
these are all really important uh
questions that
the team is working on
um when we look around at other
provinces who feel that you know they're
kind of already entering this new phase
almost of the endemic response um
is british columbia an outlier you know
how long do you see this transition
we're undergoing right now to laugh
i don't actually think we're an outlier
in any way um we the measures that we
took were not the same as some other
provinces
we're right on track we've removed all
of our capacity limits and things like
that for example on a number of
different settings so
there are a couple of fundamental pieces
that we still have in place and we've
been looking for example for mass
mandates and we've been looking at what
are the natural transition times and
what amount of transmission in our
community means that these additional
barriers are not as needed as they are
when we have high rates of transmission
and one of the really important natural
breaks that we're seeing and is looking
really optimistic is
is spring break for uh for k-12 and that
starts on on march 14th so i think
across the the country we're quite
aligned on having some basic things in
place uh different provinces and
territories have used things like their
vaccine card in different ways it is an
important tool that is still having
really important effects and
is in in play here in bc still but those
are all things that are additional
layers of protection that as
transmission comes down as our
hospitalization comes down and the risk
in the communities changes we can shift
more to uh individualized personal
personal management and you know all of
this is aligned with having new vaccines
available
the high level of immunity from people
stepping up and getting vaccinated in bc
and extra tools like having the the
at-home tests that people can use to
help guide their own actions over the
next few months but really it is
preparing us that we we are and we've
had this discussion with my colleagues
across the country
even this morning
we are in a transition phase we do not
yet know enough about
this virus
from an epidemiologic point of view for
us to consider it endemic that
presupposes that we know the patterns
that we're going to see through
respiratory season we have a pretty good
idea now
but
there's still a lot of this fire
circulating around the globe so there
are
inevitably going to be changes and
surprises that we will need to adapt to
just to say that i think
our approach has been
uh
founded on the advice from the
provincial health office from the bccdc
and has been i think uh compared to
other jurisdictions not just in canada
but around the world
the most consistent approach that has
meant that for children in schools
they've had the most opportunity to be
in school of all the jurisdictions
because we've taken a contin consistent
approach and have had the remarkable
work of not just people in public health
but of teachers the support of parents
and the children themselves i think our
approach has been consistent in
in well it may not feel this way living
in british columbia all the time when
measures change we've had the most
consistent approach to public health
matters and that that has led in part i
think in addition to the contributions
of british columbians the most
significant adherence to public health
measures because it is the in that the
adherence that's been the most important
thing people in bc have pitched in and
it's been exceptional we have some of
the highest rates of vaccination in the
world these are parts of our approach
and there are some differences at times
between jurisdictions british columbia
was one of the first with the bc vaccine
card
first to implement it where the
jurisdiction in canada or one of the
jurisdictions in canada one of the
largest jurisdiction in canada that has
and we have benefited from this
extraordinarily during this most recent
wave of cobit 19. all of our health care
workers and our facilities vaccinated so
we've been consistent and thoughtful i
think the response
from the public has followed that to a
great degree and has supported that
that's something that we've all done
together here this isn't common in other
jurisdictions it's what we've done here
we've dealt with this as our pandemic in
bc it's affected regions of the of
british columbia differently and at
different times but we have i think
supported one another in an exceptional
way so i'm pretty proud of british
columbia and we're going to continue to
follow that approach as we deal with
this next phase of the pandemic which
still of course exists and still affects
people in our hospitals and our
communities
next question comes from binder sagin
ctv news
um hi dr henry i just wanted to clarify
something that i thought i heard you say
which was that uh there could be
additional precautions this spring i i
know you're talking about lifting
restrictions so i'm a bit confused about
that could you just um let me know what
you were saying there a little bit
earlier
no i was talking about uh
the layers of protection and as we uh
have decreasing risk um that would
they're no longer needed but that we
need to pay attention to next fall
because we know there will be
respiratory virus resurgence and we
expect we've seen that there's a pattern
for to uh to covet as well so we may
need these additional layers of
protection again
as we move into next fall so if i said
spring that was a mistake i'm talking
about next
next fall and winter
i do thank you and at least i know kind
of touch on this too but
what i'm hearing and i'm sure you hear
it too uh from people is they look at
other provinces who are you know lifting
mass mandates vaccine dates etc and say
what's different about bc here and i
know we've talked about we've heard you
talk about uh how the restrictions have
just been generally different um but can
you tell us in terms of like the science
is it science is it politics like why
are things a little bit different here
in bc
yes probably
yeah it's probably everything
everything about that you know it's how
we have used what we've done and i think
if you look at actually what is
happening in provinces and you put it
down and you look at dates and you look
at what's happening where and what
restrictions are in place we're all very
much aligned so things that are
announced that are happening at a time
in the future
it's a way
that some people have been working
through this and you know what we've
done is
given a timeline for when we're revising
things we've had
the layers of protection in place in the
settings where they're most at risk and
you know if we look at the vc vaccine
card and where we've used the bc's
vaccine card it has been focusing
absolutely
on those highest risk indoor settings in
discretionary settings and so it has a
really important role in helping build
confidence going back into those
settings as we've come through this wave
and we know that it does reduce risk to
have only vaccinated people because we
know that over 60 percent now of people
who are vaccinated have had their
booster dose and that reduces risk of
transmission so yes we are following the
process that we've been using and that
is slightly different than how other
provinces have used their uh their
vaccine card so um it's all the same
science it's how it's been implemented
and where we've been using things what
restrictions are in place when and where
that have varied a little bit between
provinces coming back to minister dix
just to say i think
what's the same in bc is the same
approach
following
what we see in the pandemic here in bc
led on the epidemiological side by
public health and of course so it's
reasonable to ask what's different about
bc or when might reasonably aspire
what's different about other provinces i
don't know if that's the important
question i think people generally are
going the same direction but what's been
different about bc and what's remarkable
about bc
i think is
the outcomes
which generally have been very good here
compared to any other jurisdiction in
north america
first of all just let the bell ring
the outcomes have been very good and i
think our response has been consistent
so it's not a race of a few days i think
when province just announced changes
today
and so we're going to continue to follow
the same approach and i think that's
what people in bc want they want
we've had in many cases relatively fewer
measures more consistency of measures
and so whether
it happens one day or one week in one
province and one day in one week in
another province isn't the important
question i think the overall
approach continues to be the same
continues to be led by
the response to the pandemic and the
need to support public health and i say
this one thing finally
while we have
less than half of what we had the people
in the hospital that we had with covid19
at the height
of this wave we've still got a
significant number of people in the
hospital we still have people affected
in our health care system as you see in
the numbers so we continue to to have to
be cautious and that's why you see a
thoughtful balanced approach that has
been
i think supported by public health from
the beginning here and you're going to
continue to see it
next question goes to richard zusman
global news
henry i'm sure people will get the
impression listening to you today that
uh by spring break we will have at least
the masked mandate and the vaccine card
potentially eased
would there still be support from the
province when these changes come in
place for
different businesses or retailers to
keep those things in place or will the
guidance be when they're gone they are
gone uh no matter what
yeah it is
yeah so i i will say um we are
talking with all of the involved
stakeholders there's a whole lot of
things that go on behind the scenes of
how we make those decisions about timing
and what happens where but you raise a
really good point and i've tried to say
this a number of times we're moving to a
transition where people have to make
those decisions for themselves around
what are the important things you need
to do we know that there are people in
our workplaces people in our social
networks who are immune compromised who
are older who we want to spend time with
where we know the vaccines don't work as
well their immune systems are
we may not even be aware of those people
so yes we all need to continue to be
respectful we need to have it a mass
positive environment we know that it
makes a difference and particularly as
we are continuing to see transmission in
the community
it will make an important difference for
some people
to continue to do that and and
we all need to respect that and support
that particularly in schools and in some
of the other indoor environments so i
absolutely will support businesses
continuing to
protect their workers making sure that
depending on what the business is and
the risk and that they can can continue
to use the bc vaccine card it is an
important tool that helps people in
different situations that masking will
still be supported in many of those
indoor environments where we know it is
riskier and it will be different in
different communities
and i will also say that these are not
tools that we abandon they are things
that helped us that worked they're part
of the strategies that we've had um as
we before we had vaccination they were
the only strategies we have now we have
that level of immunity but that's going
to change and wane over time and there's
still we many things we don't know about
this virus and how it's going to change
so we need to keep those in our back
pocket for those times when we might
need to use them again
i know spring break is a very natural
transition point as you alluded to
is there any um
pressure on changing the rules because
we may have an influx in bc from people
from other jurisdictions where they will
no longer have mass mandates or vaccine
cards like by spring break when people
move around is that being factored at
all that we'd like to have sort of
um
a universal
set of policies across the country
uh actually
i actually hadn't thought about that if
you think about it right now um
saskatchewan as
as my colleague in saskatchewan reminded
us this morning spring comes early in
saskatchewan so they're on their spring
break right now um as our quebec and
we've known that in the last couple of
years
that we get a lot of people who come to
bc at this period of time so no the
measures that are in place in bc are in
place because
of the transmission and the data that
we're seeing in our province and we
expect that if people come here whether
it's going to whistler or going to big
white or coming to vancouver that they
follow the rules that we have in place
in the province here
but i also know that a lot of people are
looking at
this last two years has been difficult
and they want to have that break and
many people will be traveling and so
these are times a natural transition
time and really important for all of us
um who have been thinking about these
for the last
in some detail is trying to give a
normal a sense of normalcy to schools uh
for the end of the year so we are
working really closely uh with the
school uh the k-12 but also the early
childhood educators in our child care
sector and post-secondary to see you
know what what can we do to relieve that
pressure on young people
in school settings particularly
dr henry you talked about immunity
waning and so i'm just wondering if you
can discuss like how will we know what
you've learned from looking i'm guessing
at israel of when we might get a fourth
those of what we have now or would you
wait until there was a new formulation
for whatever as you said may be coming
down the line
yeah lots of lots of questions and i
think those are questions that we're all
asking around the world um yes we've
watched what's going on in israel we've
watched
ontario has given a fourth dose to some
people in their long-term care
but we're also all have slightly
different programs we went very early in
vc to the extended interval between dose
one and dose two and we kept with the
six months for the booster dose even in
our long-term care homes and that has
proven very effective at giving
stronger longer lasting immunity
so we are watching and we'll continue to
look at things like breakthrough
infections who's being affected how
severe illness is happening
and monitoring the the changes in the
virus and the whole genome sequencing is
a big part of that um so yes
it will be a matter of timing and a
matter of who so there are many
different scenarios that we could face
we could face a
very different virus for which
everybody
that has immune escape
which means that we're all again
susceptible in which case we would need
a booster dose for the broad population
the other scenarios that we could face
and we've been thinking through this is
is
a different virus that has more
impact on older people in which case
only a target group of people might need
a booster dose and that might be um in
the
in the fall next year so there's lots of
different unknowns i think i'm trying to
say that i do think it's very likely
we're going to need a fourth dose of
booster dose for people who are most at
risk and
that's our elders and seniors in
long-term care it likely won't be in the
next few
weeks to months
but those are questions that we're
working through
well
perfect answer
and answered a lot um and i don't know
if this next one is for minister dicks
or for you dr henry but you know you
eased restrictions a bit allowing
dancing and whatnot and we've seen some
videos of places over the weekend where
you know
it looked like a party like we've had
before the pandemic masks off people
dancing people milling around and i'm
just wondering is there any more
um
are there any more fines being given out
or by law officers still going out are
we sort of throwing our hands up and
saying you know we're going in that
direction so things will be what they'll
be
you know i think we are i think we are
trying to shift to personal
responsibility and business
responsibilities it still is an
important thing for
people who live who live or who work in
those
in those settings to make sure that
they're protected and that's why we have
things we've done things in a sequential
way we have the immunization rates that
are very high we know that that makes a
difference it reduces risk substantially
that's why the bc vaccine card is still
in play in those places so that
mitigates the risk that we're seeing
i just think it's time that we
we do come together it's important for
us to experience those things that we
haven't for a long time particularly for
younger people and yes you know we do
ask you to to wear masks but
um you know i i realize that for uh
owners and operators of these businesses
sometimes that can be challenging and so
we're supporting them and helping to do
that in a way that's non-punitive
but just to say the bc vaccine card and
the mass requirements that exist are
provincial health orders they continue
to be
uh doesn't mean uh they're enforced in
every circumstances obviously that would
be important maybe not even desirable
but they're they're um they're the law
they're what we need to do right now and
i think it's really important
and has been really important to stay in
the moment in the pandemic we've had
as a result of the most recent
announcement of the
relaxation of restrictions a lot more
activity all of us i think are done or
many of us in the event have done things
that we hadn't done at previous moments
in the pandemic and i think that is both
expected and positive
but the the rules that are in place
continue to be the rules and in place
for good reason and
and
people need to follow and support those
rules and overwhelmingly overwhelmingly
they are
next question goes to cole schisler
black press
um hi thanks for taking my question uh
last week i had asked you about
accessing the post covid 19
care clinics here in bc and you had said
that a serology test is an acceptable
test to get access to
that care
um serology tests cost 75 through life
labs and i was just wondering why aren't
serology tests covered by msp
well i can well i can i could say it
depends on the situation
so uh serology tests are covered if
they're ordered by a clinician so it's
all part of that process as far as i'm
aware so uh the people who are being
referred to that clinic
where the clinician believes that that's
an important test for them to have it is
covered by msp and the minister can
correct me if i'm wrong on that over to
mr dixon that's right medically
necessary care is covered in bc i think
the concern that had been expressed
at a time when relative to the number of
people at covid there was less pcr test
positive cases and
that's certainly been the case since
the end of december the concern that
they people wouldn't have access to care
well they're going to have access to
care people with
long covert or ongoing symptoms from
their
covet 19 from covet 19 transmission
are covered for medically necessary care
and bc and that will continue to be the
case it's not
for that test or any other test a la
carte in that sense you don't get to go
in and do that but as dr henry has said
when advised by a clinician it is the
case
cole do you have a
follow-up uh yeah and thank you for that
response i'm sure that a lot of people
will be relieved to hear that um the
next question is about
how how prepared is bc if we get another
variant surge you know we're hearing
from nurses and health care workers
talking about being burnt out uh people
are leaving the industry a lot of people
are
expressing fatigue about covet measures
and i'm sure uh you know
we're all very tired of it at this point
but if you know we we ease up
restrictions and then bc gets slammed by
another surge of cases
how resilient is bc going to be in the
face of that next wave if it comes
i think that
yeah i think that is uh that is the
question that all of us are thinking
about uh globally um you know there are
a lot of
around the world we're all being faced
with um the changes that we have no
control over and this virus does that
that's what it's
that's how viruses work
what we do know more about being able to
detect them being able to find the
changes
and being able to assess the impacts and
i was talking a little bit in the answer
to other questions earlier you know
there are many different scenarios that
we can see in the future some of them
would be
more severe illness some of them will be
more transmissible less severe
it's how well a virus can escape the
immune protection we have through
vaccination which is
proving to be relatively robust which is
the good news especially against severe
illness so
the answer really is
we don't know what's going to happen
next and we need to find some way of
finding some breathing room for our
health care system our health care
workers and for everybody else
who's been tired through all this so
that's why we're taking things slow
right now
so that we can relieve that pressure in
a measured way and be prepared for
what's coming next
we're also spending a lot of time
looking at and
i'll turn it over to the minister about
this looking at how do we bolster our
health human resources in particular you
know we have lost people because of
being tired and being burnt out being
sick
so how do we support people coming into
the health care system so that we are
more resilient and more robust we've
we've seen those weaknesses in our care
system that we need to address
i i think
there's two points the first is that
there are
exceptional challenges continuing to
face our health care systems why we
announced
602 new nurse training positions last
week why we've added more than 6 000
people to the seniors care sector
with our
with the program that we announced in
september of 2020 the hcap program and
others that have supported long-term
care so the health human resources
question is a central question and we'll
be presenting a plan on that shortly
that builds on the work that we're doing
but it is significant i just want to
also remind people that
there's the
the all of the effort that's part of
surgical renewal we have because of the
work of health care workers fewer people
on waiting lists for surgery doesn't
mean they're not a lot of people waiting
a long time for surgeries but fewer than
there were at the beginning of the
pandemic which is an achievement of our
health care system
but finally i'd just like to note
there's another public health emergency
that profoundly affects health care
workers but mostly communities and
people in every part of bc the overdose
public health emergency
and so on all of these efforts and more
the health care system as i would expect
have as busy a year in 2022 is 2021 and
it reminds us of why we need to take the
steps we continue to take the steps and
continue to live in the present with
respect to the covenant pandemic because
there are many other challenges people
in need of care and we need to provide
them with support and so those efforts
are going to continue and they're uh
they're significant focus in some ways
the challenges of the this year are just
as significant as they were in 2021 and
2020 the only they'll be somewhat
different
but you're quite right our healthcare
workers our nurses our health sciences
professionals our care aids the people
who put food on the table in our
healthcare facilities all of those
people and of course our doctors and
many more
all of them been affected by this and we
need to support them understanding that
this is going to be an exceptionally
busy year for health care
we have time for one more question today
we go to bell puree cbc
have our answers in english and french
please dr henry an update please how
many cases of the ba2 variant have been
detected in bc and you know i'm just
wondering you've talked about how to be
prepared for another wave but what are
your concerns about this variant given
what's happening in other parts of the
world
yeah so i i actually don't so i i
actually don't have the numbers but i
can get them for you i know we've been
following it it's been different in
different parts of the province so it
has been increasing but slowly uh the va
0.2
in bc and i think what we are learning
and what we're um
what i'm hearing from my lab colleagues
really is that it's around timing of
when it was introduced so we're not
seeing it rapidly take over i have
obviously been watching really carefully
about
what we what we know about ba point 2.
there's also a ba 0.3 and there's a a
number of others as well
we haven't seen any of the 0.3 in in in
bc yet
um
so it does seem to be more transmissible
and that may be the reason that we're
seeing certain pockets around
bc having
more cases than other places
but it does not seem to to cause more
severe illness or to have more ability
to evade the immune system
so those are things we're watching
carefully
yes these are all concerns that we have
and it's going to be the thing we're not
looking for as what happened with
omicron that suddenly is going to appear
so we need to be prepared for all of it
i will say the one other one that we're
watching carefully is that there's been
delta omicron
variants that have been found in
australia in the uk
in small clusters and a few other places
we have not yet seen any of that in
british columbia but we our whole genome
sequencing again can detect that variant
as well
thanks
dr henry navy pal
particularly
[Music]
[Music]
bell do you have a follow-up
i do please foreign minister dix in
english and french please um you talked
about the
millions of rapid tests that are going
to come to british columbia over the
next three to four weeks so i'm
wondering how soon will people younger
than 70 be able to pick them up at
pharmacies and and that number you gave
us about how many people over 70 have
collected their rapid tests um you know
is it starting to plateau could uh tests
that were put aside for them now be
given to people in other age groups
okay um about 70 000 seniors more or
less have
picked up their rapid tests those over
70
and uh and remember in some communities
that started on monday and may in a
number it started on friday so that's
just starting
but we're going to work our way through
the age groups i think fairly quickly
and so we're going to give an
opportunity in the next few days for
those over 70
to get access to their rapid tests and
we're going to move our way fairly
quickly down the age group so
i would expect that to happen in the
coming
in the coming days and that will be
announced
on various government websites and we'll
let you know and social media platforms
as well and we'll let people know
through you and members of the media and
communities when that's going to happen
and then we're just going to work our
way through many young people of course
parents have access to those tests
because of the large distribution in in
k-12 and post-secondary education
already so you see that in those parts
of the the community and so we're going
to be working our way through
65 60 55 etc in the coming weeks in a
similar way do we to what we did in
vaccinations uh
all right dr bonnie henry and health
minister adrian dix providing bc's
pandemic update dr bonnie henry says we
are seeing encouraging trends the
numbers are going down but we are still
seeing widespread transmission across
the province and we still have a
significant number of people in hospital
in terms of lifting restrictions we will
likely see some easing of restrictions
as we approach spring break some good
news there and she says we will likely
not need those extra layers of
protection in the months
uh
the kindergarten